[Music]
what is up everybody how's it going
happy Monday
playing some animal crossing today hope
you guys had a good weekend hope it was
chill hope Easter was fun hope everyone
stayed safe sorry this is my favorite
song in Animal Crossing KK house it's
pretty jammin and if KK comes to your
Island you can specifically request a
song of his if you type it in perfectly
and the acoustic version of this song
even better um what's up everyone how's
it going today we are just chilling you
know it's the start of the week and you
know I just want to relax have fun and
animal Crossing's it's the best place to
do that I'm gonna give a little island
tour today and then later I'm gonna open
up the island have you guys on and place
some fun games you'll notice I have a
lot of stuff scattered around the island
when we do the tour but that's a part of
the little scavenger hunt later and I'll
get into the details more of that but I
got some gold nuggets up for grabs for
you guys if you join in on the little
the little games I got planned later all
right so let's go ahead and yes welcome
to my my humble abode my home I haven't
walked on the foot I haven't unlocked
every single room yup I'm getting there
what's good guys
yo chill with the spam guys chill with a
spam yo Brandon what's good everybody in
the Chad Jessica ratio Sarafina doctor
chops pizza for you one two three
Vincent everybody what is good yeah so
you'll see a little bit later when I'm
walking around more but I have some
stuff scattered around and there's gonna
be specific items I'm looking for and if
you bring me those items you could get a
gold nugget all right all right
I did Brandon check out the shirt made
it just for the stream so you guys so
you guys know you know we're here oh boo
the sweet tunes yeah yeah all right now
everywhere we go that has a radio best
believe KK house is clean
all right um so I guess we'll start with
my house here even though I don't have
every floor unlocked just yet bathroom
first cuz I feel like that's the most
underleveled part like it's nice but you
know it's just a little plain no
bathroom oh I don't have a radio in here
I gotta fix that I've gotta fix that
right now actually
because oh wait I don't think I have an
extra radio actually nevermind yeah
trust me I got I got some good you guys
see right there looking at I got some
gold nuggets for you guys Laurie I love
them joking all right check in out the
kitchen next I'm cheap gamespot yup
that's right math riot waffles got my
kitchen I'm very much enjoying the pink
vibes right now Oh hold up hold up you
guys are ready no
and you could turn up the volume on this
too oh we got a crank it full glass got
my little hamster in here my toast
gotta have the toast yeah yes I want to
see it pop better know how long it takes
yeah all right cool
one of the other really funny things is
like do you want to change your outfit
in the frigerator yes so many toilets oh
my gosh oh nice Jessica sighs she's got
the same setup she knows what's up
she's got the eye for design I head over
to Maya I'm a bedroom my fast vibe jack
oh snap yeah I had to have there are key
caps in here I love having my friends
over and then we all just play and then
I use a little emotes what you woke up
EP got this giant clock on the wall that
you can't even really see so much pink
yes of course of course on my TV also
they had some like robot versus monster
TV show on earlier turn that off all
right oh wait before we leave the house
you gotta see the buddy room all the
stuff that I made with all the eggs it
was fun but I'm glad the bunny event is
completed I'm glad I got everything and
yeah I had the whole outfit but I took
it off of my wand setup but it's okay we
reppin gamespot to date with the shirt
yes that was awesome Jessica well we've
got a lot more in store and if you're
free I'm opening up the eye
later three guys come check it out so
all right now we're stepping out into
the islands oh it's raining on my ionely
now it was cloudy all day and it just
started raining which is kind of sad I
went and showed up and in sunny but it's
fine maybe you guys can catch that rainy
fish I forgot his name I haven't caught
him yet either but he only comes out in
the rain I'm leaving this turn up here
because I'm trying to spawn ants for my
museum so it's come on really leave
those there but you might notice other
things laying around so this is my porch
[Music]
it's not his head I swear it's a toy he
goes with you and you get all the items
obviously more pink for my house but my
house itself is like neutral colored I
didn't like the actual pink colored
houses options they had so I just made
everything else pink when it was cherry
blossom season the trees looked really
nice um let's see where should we go
first let's go visit Henry's house first
so Henry's house is this way we've got
you know a little fishing area if you
guys didn't know you can customize these
signs to say it like a bunch of
different things I wish they had one for
camp site but they don't but they have
one for pretty much everything else
houses orchards fishing spots we're
gonna go see Henry he lives in the apple
orchard now Henry's I'm gonna show you
guys Henry's apartment who's in the
department is very nice it is a total
aesthetic I feel like my own actual
house if you can sell buys my coffee
table back there I totally dig his vibe
I love his style that's what's up Henry
what's good I accidentally gave him more
than one game word like I was gonna give
him one I forgot I gave him one already
and now he just he's such a pal he's
such a pal he's using them both anyways
I appreciate you Henry looks good
what's good snooze it
[Music]
Oh Brandon duties are you in here
Henry was thinking about you that was
the name of Brandon's Island alright
yeah and then even henry has his own
private beach small private beaches got
his own silo here as well and and his
own bath you know I see him sitting on
these stools from time to time very nice
man I said I like Brandon umbrella all
right keep it movin
I'll show you guys my nightclub I have
going on over here yeah and you already
know what song is playing so you guys
some lovers we're gonna dance and I'm
gonna be the DJ we're gonna take some
pictures gonna be live and this dude -
wait wait let me yeah
[Music]
okay the song is too good man it's too
good sorry let's circle around you know
a nice open beach and this is Renee's
house keep an eye on furniture out here
you guys could win some gold nuggets
later she's got also her own private
beach here privacy separated by these
coconut trees that was the goal that was
the plan
Renee is awesome this is the entrance we
are out of 5 star rating so I just
started spawning some
lilies-of-the-valley
I've been putting them out here in the
front I think they're so pretty and if
we keep on walking now we have the
entrance to the museum I miss going to
museums to be honest so I felt like I
had to make my museum area extra-special
so I finally got all the fossils and
then I have some of the extra fossils
out here because they make for great
displays the super awesome these designs
I have here on these panels are actually
custom designs that I found on Twitter
if you guys go to the hashtag Animal
Crossing designs there are so many
awesome designs with people making
there's a lot of cool resources to help
but just like make your island pop so I
really really love it show the map oh
boy
[Music]
here's my map I have so many paths and
stuff going on I have my little lover's
peak up in the top right I want to show
you guys that my rock island looks crazy
so I basically forest spawned all my
rocks into one area so it makes it
easier to farm them and I'll show you
guys that in a second so let me see it
let me uh I just wanna show you guys the
dinosaurs
[Music]
blathers sleeping we won't bother him
I'm super excited about the dances I was
waiting for like the last two fossils
for forever I timed in like 60 fossils
before they finally finally had the last
two I needed so got all those in the
front oh snap
and I love Annabelle she's so cute
yeah all the dinos Bay big this falls
head I was looking for it for a long
time and then this in Cleo so the other
the Diplodocus but this guy's but I
needed his butt for a while so finally
we got them all got the t-rex this one's
my favorite though because he can't even
look at the whole dinosaur without just
going all the way up and reading his
description so really awesome God mom
dad mom yes Renee I'm Teddy I really
like everyone with the pen names all
these bad boys I have one of these in
one of my villagers all right and it
looks really funny but I love it
using the fossils as decorations started
you know being a big thing after I got
them all so you'll probably see them
scattered around a bit
I also have all the sharks if you guys
want to check out dip oh lo Duca
I can't pronounce dinosaur names I just
try to I just wanna show you guys the
Sharks the hard part for me right now I
think is catching all of the the Bucks
there's so many bugs and some of the
bugs are getting really fast I still
have a lot of fish to catch but I spent
a few days on my friends island in the
southern hemisphere to get these sharks
it was totally worth it cuz this is my
favorite tank in the whole museum the
museum is probably my favorite place in
this whole game it's just so nice oh
snap
justice the ocean sunfish
he's so when I pulled that thing out the
water oh my gosh I flipped out
it was crazy-looking but super awesome
now this is definitely my favorite tank
it's so nice in peaceful
[Music]
yeah the whale shark he's just chillin
they have two sharks in this other tank
though like they didn't put in here yeah
a doom Slayer what's good welcome back
I'm gonna sweep first I still have so
many fish catch but I did get Nemo and
Dory and the ribbon eel finally the
butter fish or whatever they're called
butterflies they're super cute this yeah
there's the Hammerhead they separated
him from the rest and the saw strikes at
the bottom but it's so peaceful I miss
going to museums all right let's go
check out the rest of the island I would
go to the bugs but I'm really missing a
lot and I think the butterflies area is
probably the only area that looks super
nice because what I have the most of
right now I think but I want to finish
up the island tour and then get you guys
on the island so we could play some
games and also we need to have a jam
session I have a performing stage I set
up so yeah that's the museum this is
resident services with the fountain in
front got Claud over there labels
actually here is lone you guys meet her
see the two signs here because we got
nuts and
the able sister is here and this pathway
this goes all the way around it's like
ten million places to sit
this is Teddy's house teddy is my jock
and you already know got my song on he's
my jock so I made sure I gave him
everything he needs to be the best he
can be you know oh come on yeah that's
where I go to relieve stress and if this
isn't facts I don't know what else is
know right now here we just sleep it and
that's me all right
Annabel excuse me darling thank you oh
and Rex everybody's not here chilling
here's Rex's beach Rex's chill though
you know so he kind of shares his beach
with the public he's down with that and
then this is Faunus private beach so
she's fancy what's up prof we I do in an
island sore and then we're gonna open up
the island and play some Island games in
the rain so bring your umbrellas please
yeah here's faunas I also tried to make
sure everyone's house had a few
entrances and exits so that it's easier
to walk around got our little love pond
here once I got the island designer I
made so many heart-shaped things it was
crazy
next we are gonna go up to Rex's house
he's got the fossil head in his backyard
here
and then he's also you know he likes to
eat the first time he told me I was
thinking about moving away I want to try
all the food in the world and I was like
what I don't want you to move away so
I'm just gonna bring you all the foods
so now I you know I gave him a little
clay furnace so he could cook what every
once I got him a smoker which fell out
of a tree which was awesome and perfect
that's the marshmallows and the kebabs
all just for him because you know I love
him I love all my villagers you just
have to keep on building house plots for
them and then you can go to the mystery
islands and they'll be villagers there
and then you keep on asking them to move
in um no yeah we're moving on maybe try
it and skip anything I've put so much
stuff on my island that I'm starting to
even get lost sometimes
this is Tasha's I wish she was telling
me because the inside of Tasha's house
looks so cool she has like a reining
wallpaper
he's got her a big beach area with the
bonfire it's got a well over here
pancetta is out there chillin here's the
stage you guys and I want us all to come
and perform some cake a house oops it
was already playing it just wasn't that
loud yeah turn it up when I first built
this stage my favourite villager walked
up to this mic and started singing KK
House I was like yeah I even got a
little snippet of it but maybe I'll play
it later but I freaked out I was like oh
my god this game is the best so yeah
when you guys come over we have to have
a jam session
because I made it to where all of these
can be stood at except you have to walk
in from a very specific area so if you
want to sing wanna play saxophone or if
you won't play guitar we can jam out all
right
this is Annabelle's house you know she's
my superstar so I had to make sure she
had a mic back here
big fancy pool you know look coconut
drink cuz she deserves the finest things
in life my little pop star and then
behind the Performing stage oh wait I do
want to show you guys well you'll be
able to see it from lovers feet so hello
[Music]
so yeah I just built this fishing area
equipped with a bunch of stuff from the
fishing tournament like the bait in
everything so we'll keep on going okay
now I can show you this I have so many
seashells I've been neglecting this side
of the island clearly just get these out
of the way but I got this lighthouse and
when I first got it I wasn't sure I was
gonna like it but they made the base the
same color as the stone and I was like
oh this is perfect
I don't know why the light's not showing
right now but at night the light does
show which is pretty cool
let's go up two hairs clots with hit
clots house first saying it got a couple
of fossils here for his decor let's turn
on the light come on there we go
oh you just can't see it I keep thinking
since it's rainy and dark that the
lights would show um we'll go this way
this is lovers this area is for all of
your photo op the needs you want to
bring a friend have the seat pick some
photos you now have some virtual
playdates Venus little heart-shaped
island here then flop down picnic table
I thought a different color flower was
growing but it just looks a different
color here
really Milan is just ten million places
to sit down all right let's go through
the back entrance of ten Chevy's house I
have a brand new ramp over here and I
want to make good use of it
this is Pan Shetty's house
she's very fashionable very fashionable
the inside of her house is all nice and
yellow and has lilies so I put some
yellow lilies out here for her she's so
cute I love her
you can jump if the square is the square
is one Tyler less oh wait I don't want
to go this way into Rock Island I want
to show the other side for you guys the
entrance the cool part we'll go through
we'll go through area
cherry tea garden now this is my cherry
tea garden I tried to separate all my
fruits into very specific areas so I did
get all the cherry blossom recipes which
is super awesome I actually thought I
was missing one for a while but they put
the cherry blossom pond stone with the
stone stuff so I did have it I was like
looking around for no reason so yeah
that's my cherry tea garden
[Music]
and then goes this way back through
Rex's because I want to go through the
front entrance of the book my own
personal money rock islands right here
so every day there wasn't a rock in this
area I would mine it and then I would
break it and hope it would spawn up here
and finally all of my rocks spawned up
here so I created this nice little path
and I designed it in a way although I
tried to make this Sam squares blend in
I designed it in a way I can still mine
all the rocks with darf you know the two
whole tech so you can still dig in the
sand so I can still mine my rock I
already mined I'm sitting so I'm not
going to do it but yeah so I set it up
and then I blended in some regular
garden rocks before I started playing
this the weekend of the lunch that's
when my switch came in my own personal
money Rock Island it just makes it
easier to farm them all when they're in
one spot
I just got that recipe today I had to
put it down this is the campsite
oh-ho and you already know okay yeah our
campsite this picnic rug thing is a
custom design I'm telling you the custom
designs are a godsend and then house is
just a little
little fishing area at the top next to
the campsite it looks really cute when
there's someone actually visiting and
there's a little tent here so no I think
Shelby's house is the only house I
haven't shot yet
so this is Debbie's house she's one of
my favorite villages this is the first
area is decorated actually even before
my own house because he was my favorite
this whole little area of him once I
really started designing and a lot of
the other villagers were had a lot more
space I kind of felt that so I extended
his area to the civil French how did I
get the regular rocks to spawn there so
basically every day that a rock wasn't
there like wasn't up there I would just
mine it and break it and then hope it
would spawn and then eventually it
spawned up there what's up Dobby yes I
do want to talk to you this all this
stuff I gave him he puts it out even
though he still has boxes for Fran sure
I give him so many tables and stuff and
he still uses the boxes and staples I
don't understand and yeah that is pretty
much the island so I hope you guys
enjoyed it now Rex don't be telling me
you want to move out oh I can't read
this because my camera is in the way nah
it works for you Rex you stay you just
the way you are I get all sad when my
villages are like second second guessing
themselves I'm like
all right so it's time to open the
island and have you guys over sorry I
can't see this the stream platform
instead of right here we go I'm gonna
make a dodo code now when you join in
don't start right away on the scavenger
hunt plus I didn't even tell you what I
was looking for yet to reward you I'm
doing it this way too so that I don't
have to like go through the whole friend
code and everything every single time so
yes my island tun is the Lost Woods our
ride gates are open and the Dodos code
is 7 s 8 8 9 7 s 8 8 9 I should write
that down I have all these other coda
quotes on my wall in the same by people
in 7s a thanks are evil so yeah whenever
you guys get here just meet up with me
at the Plaza
Oh actually do I have no see if I can
make it in time Princip enjoy oh there
we go
already ah okay just meet me at the
Plaza when you're ready oh yeah on the
way let's go
[Music]
is it full already or is it only just
like one at a time
[Music]
you might have to keep searching cause
like I think you don't I don't actually
know how that works
it's full already ins Argus
I wish they would allow like more people
on set I think eight is a limit
including the host so really only like
seven people can come to your Island
seconds off guys if you like this like
if you like us doing stuff like this
then maybe we can make a case to have
like an animal crossing day or something
and I definitely want to be able to have
all you guys come and hang out
also when you're here please leave a
message on my bulletin and make me super
happy I've been kind of gathering at
bulletins notes from everyone who comes
by and whenever I might get sad or
something or I get down then I'm like I
just got read the bullets and like it
shows me up right away so one for me
sorry guys it's alright maybe after like
the first game with you well like do I
win reset and we'll do it again or if
you guys also want to start an island
you guys can start an island too and
join up with each other that's what we
did last time and a lot of people have
their islands going at the same time
which was cool Jordan that's good
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're definitely gonna be in
this screen for a while
[Music]
what happened I should go to the French
if I can make it there I was gonna try
to craft something about or no time now
yeah guys I would definitely recommend
like get your Islands going to so that
you know if you couldn't make it into
this one then someone else you make one
- squeaks what's up from hell over
Island
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna try to make it out of my door
and runs with a friend but I think we're
in the loop we're in the loop until
everyone's here I don't know how many
people that was surprising like three or
four but yay all right cool doctor chops
is making an island you guys so
definitely hop over there for sure
[Music]
welcome welcome all so cute
good there Trent you want right buddy a
nice hey you guys if you want to visit
dr. chiapas island right now go do it
his dodo coat is 4 X 1 HT T's and Tom
bum-bum-bum-bum-bum
Oh what happened did we freeze did the
island explode this has never happened
to me before
so I don't know oh my goodness what is
happening rip the island oh my goodness
come on come on online I believe in you
we've put too much of a strain we put
too much of a strain on the island you
guys Island said hold up
who said you gave all these people over
right now oh no all right I might have
to I might have to force clothes I
really hate doing that because I'm
always scared something's gonna mess up
Oh No
all right I'm sorry guys but I gotta
restart this
I really hate doing that but I will open
it up again yeah it's all good it's all
good we can open it back up again
we'll be right back at it in just a
second we have no time to waste
hopefully all the stuff that I put on
the floor is still there because it's
still raining that's good news
see you guys can try to catch that fish
if you want I'm so sorry I'm so sorry it
wasn't me I swear the game imploded
[Music]
alright it looks like all my goods are
still here
leave my turnips I'm trying to spawn
ants alright let's try this again
alright I still got the gold nuggets
also I should probably break these up
because if I accidentally give someone
all 23 I wouldn't even be mad at you and
give them back okay
alright let's try this again
oh boy I'm just gonna sit in the airport
and I'm not gonna do anything it might
have been my fault I was trying to leave
my house before something again let's
see sorry yes okay we're gonna do this
[Music]
also take some money out of my bank
thing cuz I wanted okay it's fine
might be a dud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's like a second he was like all right
till you agree to this all right what's
going to stay here 3 H 2 x8 3 H 2 x8 3 H
2 x8
[Music]
boom and here I will sit n waves because
I don't want to break anything no don't
say sorry thank you for opening up your
Island
that's awesome and the fun thing about
this game is the more friends you make
and the more people you meet the better
you guys can start trading among each
other you can start cataloging with each
other and all that's really really fun
and it helps your island grow like a
bunch of stuff in my island right now I
got from visiting my friend's islands
and like they had something I really
liked and I would catalog it if you
didn't know you can go to someone's
Island and like pick up an item of
theirs and put it like in your pocket
and then put it back on the floor and
then you'll have that item in your nook
catalog and you can go home and buy it
for yourself so if you didn't know that
was saying you can do that so yeah and
it's really helpful because sometimes
there's like pieces of furniture I
really want
and like I just can't find it like all
farm balloons and stuff from recipes
everything but yeah how is it already
full lily the first person just sign in
right now yo Brandon what's good he made
it
[Music]
oh snap yeah and the fruit tree the
fruit trade for sure your bag let's go
Henry it was missing you anyways so men
you guys are on it with the lightning
quickness I type slow as heck in this
game so the fact that you guys got in
here within like a second is crazy I'm
not good I'm not leaving the airport I'm
going to sit here in the airport and
wait I don't know where Brandon is misty
outside
I have not built the cool robot I have
the recipe and I have the Nuggets for it
but I don't have the rocket I don't have
enough rusted parts and I don't have
gold armor
[Music]
dr. Chavez island is also open if he
couldn't get in and he said he has all
the fruits so hit him up he's willing to
trade oh let's all get Bob Jones next
time Nick is here
[Music]
oh snap
we had ash I like how I sat in here
thinking I would see everyone like him
out but it just spawns you like right
inside this the airport or right outside
the airport Jordan got back in for the
second time let's go community Friday
all over again yup it's all good though
because once everyone's in then we're
good
[Music]
oh man this song yay
happy to help otaku happy the hope oh
snap looking flat wait why am I not in
the airport I'm in the airport they
should have my avatar there when you
guys are walking in no fair oh I've lost
count of how many people are in here
though
[Music]
hello Raul how's it going how you doing
happy Monday welcome to the stream we're
just getting everybody in the island on
the island words Seraphina has made it
to the island welcome welcome
[Music]
yay all right I haven't I've already
lost count of how many people joined in
right think we have like maybe two more
people on the way before it's full I
don't even remember my island hasn't
been I know I'm supposed to count I
[Music]
imagine what animal crossing would be
like if the island limit was like 25 we
would be here forever for everyone to
get off that Island oh I'm so cute love
it
Jessica you should send me a friend code
or I'll send you my friend code so hello
Oh
dangerous locked into the airport during
all of this that's how we trashed last
time Oh
Oh I'm scared to move hello oh yeah see
I was like I don't want to do it too
much right now
oh my god you guys you guys are playing
with fire walking through doors right
now playing with fire
all right everyone who joined so leave
me a message on my bulletin and be nice
squeeze are you back in this is a few
Jessica Taylor says I've been thinking
about buying this game is it worth it
I'm the wrong person to ask because I'm
going to say absolutely yes I love the
heck out of this game and you should
absolutely buy it but I'll live me this
type of game probably isn't for
everybody but it's so really fun
especially when you play with people so
yeah you know I say heck yeah
chat says heck yeah but I guess I also
have to be fair and saying it is a very
specific type of game I like farming so
I don't know if you guys ever played a
kingdom for couplings I talk about all
the time when I play this but that game
was all about farming literally and
getting resurfacing you would assign the
Catholics to work for you pretty much it
was kind of crazy but it was fun
it'd be like being I can't wait to get
50 pieces of wood and then convert that
and so you could convert the resources
into a bunch of other things
okay alright one more is on the way oh
yeah all right Oh a nice Oh Oh careful
guys where I don't want it to crash I
think this is the last spot okay
[Music]
Alijah nom nom oh yeah I forgot to tell
you guys my island is called bandle city
and my island flag has Teemo on it and
it bandle city is where teemo's from so
totally fangirling out there were other
things I did one to name my Island but
you could only have a certain amount of
characters so everything I wanted was
too long like I kind of wanted to name
my island Beaver Creek but it was one
character too long and I was like dang
so unfortunate all right I think we're
good I think we are full now
so let's go to if you have twitter you
can see miss me on twitter disco let's
see everyone meet me at the plaza
Oh No
okay whoo I was like if this loading
icon' does not show up right now I am
going to cry
hello Oh someone was on their way oh my
goodness
this is the best game for social
distancing after um the streams down
I'll I'll send my I'll send my friend
code in the chat oh snap
Joe's heart was on his way
[Music]
okay I'm Instagram bin it's the same as
my Twitter Persia underscore XO he's
right on time dude I wish I could get
into my old life space I know it was
evil as heck all right now I think we're
full i big
[Laughter]
[Music]
Hey
stylin yeah yeah the stream is like 30
seconds behind just see you guys now so
if it always seems like I take forever
to respond 1 I probably do into dairy
the delay so hello everyone we're at the
Plaza so since there is a delay I'm
gonna take some time so let you guys
pile in here now I know you guys saw
during the tour wait who else is here
you guys stay here who are we missing oh
here we go yeah alright yeah
so guys hello and I'm on doctor mode so
I can't use the screen hi alright guys
so I know you suck I know you guys saw
that we have that I had scattered random
bits of furniture and goodies on the
floor so while I take a photo of us and
my instructions catch up to the stream
so basically you guys I have put a bunch
yeah do I put a bunch of furniture items
around the island and what I'm looking
for are an ocarina if you can find an
ocarina and bring it back to me you'll
get a gold nugget
all right so whenever this stream
catches up to what I've said I will see
that everyone is dispersed also any
furniture that you do fine or in
anything on the ground that you do fine
it's yours to keep
so find an ocarina bring it back to me
and you'll win a gold nugget good luck I
will be here
I'll be around actually you'll have to
just find me oh my gosh I love that once
the stream caught up there you see
everyone like running good luck I'm
going to open my Nintendo app so I can
type on here without there we go I know
it's sorry guys
but it's okay they figured it out I hid
them in some pretty good places to sew
oh I forgot I'm still in camera mode I
was like why is my camera not me
yeah I kind of put some cool stuff out
there also oh my gosh everyone's running
around I love this so much and then you
guys gotta find me so haha good luck
to two challenges later I want us all to
go and like perform why how do you like
yellow huh yeah
yay oh so there's five ocarinas by the
way so yeah now you just have to find me
and whip though green out play me a tune
[Music]
if you found one take it out and show it
to me play it a couple times I need
proof
give me the proof I don't want you to
drop it I just want you to hold it and
yeah all right cool yeah so one for you
oh I can't put things in the plaza come
over here
[Music]
don't steal this nugget I mean it yeah
there's five in total so two were found
that means there's three more out there
somewhere row of all of them I'm like no
please honor system I'll send you the QR
code there's still three more out there
I'm like trying to remember where I hid
most of them actually so hold on me also
can I go here room right now I can't
remember if the terminal is accessible
and so when people are on my Island and
I I don't think it is
oh it is yes okay I'm gonna take some
money out I still owe so much but it's
fine because yeah all right
the island is full at the moment so who
else found one there's three more out
there there's three more out there for
sure oh he found one there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh did you find the other one all right
there you go oh did you not find the
other one okay okay all right so that's
three found that means there's two left
there's two left on the island did you
find a way I get one yeah I'm honestly
don't remember where I put them all so I
wouldn't even be able to help you guys I
know I put a few like behind people's
houses so you might need to look there
right oh wait there's one more there's
one word I can't count sorry
[Music]
[Music]
also if you guys need fruit of any kind
feel free to take you know if you need I
got all the fruits I don't remember
where they went so let me ask you this
one feels like a spoiler alerts right
here I know you found it yeah then I
think I know where the last one is oh my
gosh I'm like laughing so hard I'm
sweating clothing who else is on the
island still looking oh I'm trying to
remember the last one might be here
these two were like the hardest hidden
ones that I had no no oh no someone
found that one eh oh yeah in case you
guys didn't know that's like my easy way
of like looking around I just go into my
pockets when I'm behind a building and
it makes the building disappear and so
if you ever need help with that I
suppose thinking
actually don't remember who all I gave
buildin like its to buy now button okay
cool haha
yeah I don't remember where the last one
was so yeah yeah alright let's go - I
can tell everyone's just like what path
running through all the flowers let's go
have a little jam session there's still
one floating around out here I just
don't know where it is
oh yeah so we definitely need someone on
the pianos someone to please saxophones
from the fishing area okay cool
and then after this we can place some
musical chairs
let me tell the crew let's jam
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yay
oh my gosh everyone's here oh my
goodness yeah yeah I love it I love it
so awesome
all right when you went else like the
Jenna yeah yay thank you thank you I got
the clip I wanted fantastic
all right let's see let me see here okay
cool
all right it's musical chairs time
[Applause]
winner get okay so you guys stay there
now this hmm
so I will do
[Music]
when the music stops
oops I didn't mean to move that all
right so I know there's a delay so I'm
gonna type it to you guys in the pan
when I stop playing good luck have fun
[Music]
[Music]
all right sorry ash
all right everyone up round two ready
yes
keep walking keep walking don't stand
right next to a cherry I gotta be moving
so close all right Randy here we go
[Music]
mooo bricks I got a witness the election
No all right Randy
I mean four okay we're gonna play
another round of this after all right so
fun
[Music]
all right round by the emotes really
nice really adds impact yeah we'll do
some piano action this time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh that was so close nope all
right down to the final chair um I kind
of feel like these chairs are a little
compact but it's fun all right
final final round are we ready
I don't want to be bio sealer so I don't
want to like stop it at any time that I
know someone's walking around somewhere
so good luck wait what happened it got
very quiet was I actually I was like as
I wasn't sure we all get yeah let's go
all right come over here Oh hold up yeah
yeah everybody clap for her that was a
hard one battle yeah I don't want no
chick hey I don't want you all to steal
her purse stuff okay yeah
[Applause]
game-2 so fun no um you can still play
if you want to shine and get all my show
I'm since there's such a big stream
delay I'm gonna I'm gonna do the music
if there wasn't a bit we're gonna trap
Dobby in here he has to play with us oh
wait did I forget that one
[Music]
no I'm gonna buy it he wants to get out
you're blocking him all right are we
ready
round one
[Music]
my poor flowers
[Music]
are we missing something
oh I guess he doesn't want to play all
right that was a open round full
coverage full collision out all right
around you here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
saying nothing be in the way
oh my bad I was in the way huh we could
do that one again if you want I was in
the way with you that one again
[Music]
I want to watch right-oh and get in the
way what happened all right next round
[Music]
all right here we go
Jotaro
[Music]
alright next around you picked up
Michelle alright next around
I don't remember way around it was oops
I'm the winner just kidding right how
many people are still in right now
actually so many people all right here
we go
oh my gosh so funny
oh my gosh oh my gosh here we go
oh so close
oh yeah man I want to still pull you
guys the loopholes right the secret the
secret chair that one is a girl all
right
last Sarang all right here we go
Oh what that was like
wait wears you out last round already
though five that you were Oh blast
I mean I could be wrong you're not I'm
just trying to beat there but you know
what everyone's clapping so boom I don't
even a me mad about it let's go all
right congrats hold up this way
grab a thousand sorry I got a lot of
organizing to do
everyone's just so close yes
congratulations all right well that was
fun
Brandon you said you found the lasso
Karina oh snap
nice you found the last one the one that
was out there hiding this whole time
[Music]
that's for you Brandenburg lay down now
now that's Brandon take it Brandon
before someone else does
there you go all right well good job
everyone and thank you guys so much
um yeah that was the last of our games
actually but it was super fun and you
know played some musical chairs got a
little jam session yeah a little
scavenger hunt gave way some nuggets
gave away some bells and had a great
time I feel like that's an awesome way
to start the week I don't know about you
guys but thanks so much for playing
so yeah thank you guys so much for
playing so much for joining up go ahead
and grab any fruit you need right now
because I'm going to close the islands
after the stream of Sun but super fun
time and and yes I am going to put my
switch code actually
so I will be closing up the things soon
but feel free to add you guys you know
I'm I'm playing this game a lot actually
and if you guys are really enjoying you
know the animal crossing content in the
stuff that we're doing aside from all of
our awesome guides that we have up on
YouTube if you're really enjoying the
content and you like these live streams
and having fun like this with me then
definitely let us know we'll try to get
this poppin more often and having more
fun no second island round we're already
out of time but if you guys really
really enjoy this and really have fun
then I can definitely try to make this
happen more often I obviously have a ton
of fun doing this and I really love
having you guys over and playing these
little games and this is also a good
test of a few games that I wanted to do
like a little scavenger hunt wanted to
see how feasible it actually was so
thank you guys so much I'm going to put
my friend code in the chat actually I'll
just show it here if you guys would like
to add me my friend code is covered by
the camera noise there we go six six
thirty six oh one four three four one
three two add me you guys and we can get
these trades going you know the market
is poppin but yeah definitely have a
great one you guys I will see you all
later I'm going to close the gates very
soon so
here your fruit
there now you did win okay I feel like
everyone wants something except for you
so there you go all right you guys so
I'm going to close up the island thank
you guys so much for stopping by and for
hanging out much appreciated please stay
stay safe out there you guys and tune in
every single weekday at 2:00 p.m.
Pacific time because that's when we're
chilling and hanging out and pull in all
the games and the fact that you guys are
supporting and showing up to me and
sorrell to us so thank you so much and
have a good one peace